bon on va sortir collections permanentes
sur yuko voilà je voulais trouver
manière de le mettre en avant j'y vais
frontale ok j'en ai marre permanente
pourquoi parce que les quantités des
pièces sont plus élevés et en plus si
une pièce a beaucoup plus qu'elle est
out of stock et dans l'art fabriquer la
roue du stock est aussi c'est une
manière pour nous de se faire qui fait
de pouvoir faire des pièces one shot
basé sur un thème plutôt que de devoir
trouver un thème assez large pour
pouvoir le développer en toute une
collection ça s'ajoute au drop à thème
que ya tous les deux - d'éditions
limitées vous en faites pas rien ne
change
et aussi dans cette collection
permanente c'est l'arrivée de jogging
qui sont très confortables j'en ai
actuellement sur moi je vous ai
convaincus messieurs dames les beaux
jours reviennent vous mettez votre
masque passe quelques villes et puis de
décider de rejoindre votre petite amie
ou petits copains ou amis tout court à
l'autre bout de la ville mais savez vous
quand vous avez à faire ce trajet
aujourd'hui on va par les caméras de
surveillance et un truc très drôle avec
les caméras de surveillance et que ça
film des tas de choses qui n'ont rien à
voir avec du vol ou ce genre de truc
juste des gens qui font des trucs dans
la rue ou dans des lieux et qu'ils
oublient qu'ils sont totalement film et
moderne ya pas longtemps il ya une news
sur georges juste des gens qui ont dansé
dans un supermarché news nationale
on est tellement épuisée par le cos vite
que quand deux humains qui fait un peu
dans un supermarché
abbas a fait les gros titres je trouve
ça assez au goût de me dire que la
plupart de tes trajet et la plupart de
ce que tu fais en fait on peut le savoir
grâce à ces [ __ ] de caméras de
surveillance la chine ces pays où il ya
le plus de caméras de surveillance est
l'une des villes parmi lesquelles y en a
le plus compté une caméra pour 18
habitants a contrario en france la ville
où il ya plus de caméras de surveillance
c'est nice et il ya une caméra pour 130
habitants alors les puristes de cette
chaîne youtube se souvient de la fameuse
vidéo sur les deux rebelles caméras
qu'on a fait est un petit moment et qui
était très sympa et l'issue de laquelle
je m'étais août où l'influencé j'en
avais acheté elle a plus de batterie
depuis un an il faut dévisser une vis
pour pouvoir prendre la batterie ça
suffit à me décourager à ne plus jamais
la charge et je suis un affreux bref
aujourd'hui on a donc une petite
sélection nadeau de plein de trucs qui
sont passés devant des caméras de
surveillance et qui sont hilarantes
sachez qu'à plein de vidéo de
caméra-surveillance de voleurs qui
tourne dans le magasin en traversant le
plafond c'est assez hilarant mais il
n'est pas question de ça aujourd'hui il
ne se passe pas que des choses affreuses
devant ses caméras de surveillance
il se passe aussi des moments très
humain émouvant comme par exemple ce mec
qui s'étire avant de braquer dunkin
donuts
même quand je fais du sport je m'étire
pas lui va braquer un endroit et il
s'étire avant c'est pas un gros
quel toupet j'espère au moins qu'ils ont
engagés comme serveur celle ci est la
chaux père vrais moments de complicité
entre deux humains
regardez bien comme c'est mignon alors
déjà ça ça m'effraie voilà tout le monde
le voit et n'ose pas tant parler mais
toi tu le vois pas parce que c'est là
ton crâne c'est terrible mais ils
marchent tranquillement
il adresse au nom c'est un moment de
complicité où ils font comme si c'était
un début de combats de kung fu me dis
pas qu'il faut se reprendre dans les
bras non ok là on va un peu moins rires
donc c'est l'atelier de bricolage d'un
mec et sa caméra a filmé une intrusion
[Musique]
je laisse mon temps parce que j'ai
gardées arachnophobes et à chaque fois
il m'insulte quand on vois une araignée
donc ces voix là j'adore les insultes
alizés continuer non non ça me terrifie
quoi toi j'ai parlé de cet animal sur
cette chaîne youtube
personne ne sait évidemment mec la
cuisse as d'une autruche à ce nom mais
pas longtemps je sais pas ce qui me fait
le plus bas des si c'est ça ou la
musculature des kangourous se pose
soigneurs qui se courir après l'or en
vrai elle n'attaque pas vraiment parce
qu'une autruche ça monte à 70 km heure
si elle te veut du mal tu auras mal à ya
un pneu qui arrive au nom au nom
ceci dit je vais vous faire baver plus
qu'un vrai d'horreur vous êtes prêts il
arrive comme là qu'une voiture sur une
autoroute perdre un pneu sauf que le
pneu il est lancé à 130 kilomètres heure
donc à l'inertie rebondi etc
il ya eu deux cas où le pneu a atterri
dans la tête d'un motard directement
donc je vais dire je préfère qu'ils
arrivent tranquillement dans le cul de
ma voiture à la station essence plutôt
que dans ma tête quand je suis sur le
tour devra maintenant vous allez voir
vous allez un peu bad et quand vous
serez sur les autoroutes vous repensez à
ce moment vous direz mais quel chien
squeeze
alors excusez moi mais déjà ce chien et
me fait pas déjà
alors attends attends attends quoi
attend c'est fou mais que là ça brise
une légende la légende de l excuse de
merde du mon chien a mangé mon devoir en
fait le mec qui dit ça il est pas si
coup ça existe vraiment on fait tous des
méga vannes sur ça depuis qu'on a 12 ans
mais ça arrive vraiment à certains
d'entre eux tous et personne ne les
crois
c'est tellement injuste et deuxièmement
excuse moi ces jeunes gens là ils ont
été drogués c'est pas possible qu'ils
sont sous sédatifs
il ya une manette qui tourne ya un chien
qui saute ils sont en train de déchirer
des feuilles a4 ça ou pu tranquillement
ce n'est pas un problème toi à côté de
ça il ya un oiseau qui crie dehors ça te
réveilles tu en as pour 3h attendant
bien ça m'énerve je suis jaloux et les
deux dorment encore à ça et la lumière
s'est allumée
7h35 oh non il va découvrir qu'ils ont
nés qui essaie de voir au nom le pot
oh non c'est trop triste
et on peut pas avoir le meilleur sommeil
du monde et un chien qui mangent pas ses
copines au hockey c'est là où l'eau tu
choisis frérot au nom ça ça va être trop
mignon c'est la personne qui nettoie le
gymnase d'une université probablement et
qui apparemment est fan de basket et va
se faire un petit plaisir
[Musique]
oh non il célèbre il est trop mimi
enfants il reprend son boulot
tranquillement il s'est fait son petit
kit je trouve ça adorable félicité le
allait lui dirai bon gaza il sera trop
heureux en fait je trouve ça trop beau
parce qu'il ya personne qui le regarde
il fait juste ça pour ce faire kiffer
lui s'en bat les couilles ici c'est que
personne ne regarde une caméra de
surveillance a filmé un problème
d'ordinateur portable en charge ça à
prendre feu c'est terrifiant
c'est une grenade lanoye alors sachez
que c'est très rare mais ça arrive
les batteries genre de téléphone de
cigarettes électroniques de toutes les
batteries lithium
elles peuvent faire ça et c'est arrivé
que des mecs et leur téléphone dans
leurs poches et qui se passe ça par
conséquent tu ne peux plus te produire
après cette excellente caméras de
sécurité de maison qui a capturées
chaque mouvement
[Musique]
oui mais pas qu'à toi la tête il tourne
la dette
non il est trop mignon par en excusez
moi mais il a un cdi ce chien ou sait
comment il a son petit badge
d'entreprise autour du cou là c'est la
pause du midi s'apprêtait à retourner à
il a plus d'expérience professionnelle
que nous quand on employait de travaux
s'occupe de ton chat oh non il aime trop
les animaux du coup il est trop content
qu'ils aient un chat sur son chantier au
nom et laisse pas aller tout fait dans
cette chambre par plaisir pendant deux
trois secondes
je regarde trop de films d'horreur mais
manon m'a dit que le coq lui en voulait
aujourd'hui j'ai tchèque la caméra de
sécurité pour vérifier
je crois que dans le top 3 des trucs les
plus drôles c'est les humains qui se
font courser par un animal ça me fait
trop rire à ça j'ai vu c'est génial en
gros c'est des gens compris le rush
d'une journée d'une caméra surveillance
etc ont superposé tous les moments où il
se passe un truc du coup ça donne une
vidéo dans laquelle il se passe tous ces
trucs là au même moment et ils ont
marqué lors de chaque truc dessus c'est
globalement
maintenant je suis trop con c'est le
même os mais non je suis sûr qu'on sait
le même mec c'est juste le même nom
avoir dormi relu cas mais il ya quoi
dans ce voisinage à part juste un mec
qui passe la tondeuse c'est incroyable
biarritz passe rien excusez moi mais
c'est le même août
ok clairement le centre d'intérêt c'est
la pelouse c'est incroyable mon grand
père mac
à 92 ans et il vient d'installer des
caméras de sécurité autour de sa maison
et de temps en temps ils nous envoient
des messages random trop mignon
tellement d'innocents sherbrooke dans la
vie tu es enfant après tu vieillis et un
moment tu as tellement vieilli que tu
redeviens enfants et ces moments où tu
es le plus touchant de toute ta vie je
crois une vidéo de moi qui me fait très
peur prises par la caméra de
surveillance à temps ceci dit ces prix
devraient attaques depuis quand raza
arrive à 65 km heure sur toile à au sra
ou une autruche il a carrément d'éviter
dans la direction du mec
j'avoue badens sera pas dedans j'ai
stressé quand j'ai reçu une notification
de la caméra de surveillance à 5h du mat
[Musique]
waouw c'est le petit chat au women tous
une double vie des chats ils se
rassemblent soir ils jouent au poker et
tous et c'est sûr ok c'est un mec qui
vient d'installer une caméra devant chez
lui il faut dire que là il tombe là
dessus parce qu'il a une notification
genre ce qu'elle a détecté un mouvement
[Musique]
mais pas s'il veut plus rien si c'est le
comportement du poulet ou si c'est la
manière qu'il a de courir quand même une
grenouille tu la rattrape pas là on
prend comme ça qu'est ce qui se passe au
maire d'incroyables un garde au japon a
été pris au bon il ya marqué japon ça va
être bien pas devenir le titre ah je les
adore avec le stick lumineux c'est un
agent de la circulation du cou qui
apparemment est très investi non il
était il prend ça genre tellement à
coeur on dirait que l'avenir de
l'humanité dépend d'eux s'ils gèrent
bien cette circulation ou pas au rendez
vous avec le bâton olalala lors déjà ça
me touche de ouf j'ai eu l'immense
chance d'aller plein de fouet au japon
et à chaque fois ça c'est un truc qui me
choque vraiment c'est que les mecs sont
hyper investi je me souviens une fois 15
rbds india dans un café à côté et j'y
allais tous les jours pendant petit café
le matin c'était un peu mon petit rituel
et à chaque fois que j'arrivais ils
étaient 3 me dire il achève à celle ça
veut dire bienvenue il faisait le café
je ressens qui est une goutte qui tombe
que le sopalin soit pile bien mis dans
le sachet que tous tiennent la main il
se stresser de malades alors qu'ils
auraient juste plus genre me filer café
en disant tiens frères dégage
franchement ça me c'était cool aussi
en fait c'est trop mignon parce qu'il
pourrait mettre genre quatre fois moins
d'énergie que ça dans ton taf là le gars
est le résultat serait le même
eh ben ça c'est typique je trouve de là
bas cette gamme nature ayant à capturer
le moment où un chien a pris la
chaussure de son maître et a dormi à
côté tellement son maître il lui manque
pendant qu'il est au travail
non mais attendez soit des humains un
peu vieux mignon soin des animaux
voulait me tuer en fait la sémer de
corps sensibles les femmes exigent une
faire une tranche de pain d'épicés m'a
rendu triste
enfin chez à utiliser la surveillance
des caméras pour chasser un rat
[Musique]
est ce que c'est possible est ce que le
char reconnaît que c'est une image et
l'endroit auquel ça correspond et que
c'est en temps réel non si ou alors je
suis complètement con ella vous tapez
votre meilleur bar et vous plantez
l'écran du doigt en mots qu'est ce
qu'ils ont comme c'est pour ça que
j'adore
bah c'est saab a déjà baisse de doigts
montrent pas les gens du doigt et
ensuite je vais rien faire du tout ok
bon c'est la fin de cette vidéo c'était
sacrément ce un peu sa rentrée dans
l'intimité des gens quand ils sont
filmés à leur insu et qui le sauve pas
un
on peut être fiers d'eux bravo c'était
une expérience tout ça vous allez
banques
d'ailleurs rassurez-vous la plupart des
vidéos qu'on a regardé où était posté
par les gens qui sont dans la vidéo en
question sauf l'eau mais qui courait
après une poule mais bon je sais pas si
nous en voudra tant que ça ne s'est pas
passé une bonne soirée attribués dans
une prochaine vidéo et ça y est c'était
la première vidéo officielle avec le
nouveau décor pas mal en vrai là ça y
est c'est bon vous êtes déjà habitués et
quand on changera dont je sais pas
combien de temps vous serez triste est
ce que j'essaie de contrôler vos
sentiments peut-être peut-être un peu
allez prenez soin de vous a très vite
mais petit quizz hausse
[Musique]